grazie grazie mille
ciao a tutti è un piacere veramente
enorme per me essere qui essere uno
degli speaker di elemento telex e io
appunto mi chiamo chiara bordi o 19 anni
vengo da un paesino vicino roma e sono
qui appunto per raccontarvi come la mia
diversità damian anomalia ci ha da
sempre stata la mia più grande forza
prima di iniziare faccio un piccolo come
di una piccola premessa se mi avete
visto un po supplicare con le stampelle
perché mi sono rotto il piede buono
quello quello vero e quindi al momento
non dispongono di piedi e camminare a
meglio comunque e grasse
allora per arrivare a quello che appunto
di cui voglio parlare devo andare avanti
indietro di qualche anno esattamente nel
2013 quando appunto la mia vita è
cambiata radicalmente
era estate appunto era esattamente il 5
luglio del 2013 euro nel bel mezzo della
mia adolescenza avevo quasi 13 anni e
fidanzata con un ragazzo ero innamorata
ecco la mia prima cotta la mia prima
estate in cui viene permesso di uscire
da sola e quant'altro è infatti una sera
d'estate appunto con questo 5 luglio
2013 decidiamo di andare ad un saggio di
danza di di alcune mie amiche e una
serata perfetta nel tornare a casa
dovevo chiamare i miei genitori però non
volevo disturbare perché mio padre era
tornato appena da una missione in libano
aveva solamente cinque giorni versare a
casa mia madre avevano stabilimento
balneare io abitavo abbastanza vicino
dal centro e quindi inizialmente ho
deciso di andare a piedi in questo
ragazzo mi ha offerto generosamente un
passaggio motorino e così siamo andati
nella nostra la nostra strada sia
interrotta in realtà dopo pochissimi
metri quando una macchina ci ha tagliato
la strada girando in contromano per me è
stato veramente una frazione di secondo
mi ricordo solamente il rumore
assordante e
e poi insomma il mio corpo seduto a
gambe incrociate un dolore lancinante
comunque nel momento in cui mi sono
iniziati a un po guardare addosso visto
l'omero il femore rotto e ok era
qualcosa che si è come dire era successo
però probabilmente non era così tanto
grave è la parte più brutta è stato
appunto quando sono arrivato al piede mi
dispiace per i vostri stomaci però l'ho
visto diciamo in una pozza di sangue e
in quel momento è veramente crollato il
mondo addosso
[Musica]
come dire la mia la visione del mio
futuro in quel momento si è come
azzerata e tutte le certezze che avevo
in quel momento erano state distrutte
non immaginavo un futuro ma non sapevo
come immaginarlo perché ormai la mia
realtà avevo capito che sarebbe in
ambiato in quel preciso istante
e infatti poi mi hanno portato va bene
all'ospedale del mio del mio paese e
mando avanti un pezzettino solo per
nella portata dell'ospedale mio paese
avevo sentito i medici parlare e dire
proprio che probabilmente non sarei
arrivata viva al gemelli all'ospedale a
roma in quel momento io ho detto ok e
probabilmente rischia di morire però mi
sono aggrappata a quella speranza mi
sono aggrappata a tutto
tutte le cose che avevo ancora che
dovevo ancora fare che volevo fare che
volevo raggiungere e da auto convincermi
del fatto che non sarebbe finita quel
giorno è quella sera e ho detto la mia
vita è ancora troppo lunga
devo rimanere sveglia infatti
sono passate quattro ore e mezza prima
viene dico altro mi portasse fino a roma
e sono stata cosciente fino fino alla
fine pregato in ginocchio veramente
chiunque di salvarmi il piede se fosse
stato possibile ma ovviamente per quello
dice quando avevo troppe troppe speranze
e mi sono risvegliato in sala in terapia
intensiva e quei giorni di ricordo
veramente difficili perché i miei
genitori ne sarà lo potranno entrare
solamente un'ora durante la giornata e
quindi io
nell'arco di tutta la giornata ripensavo
a cosa che era successo ripensavo alle
cose che probabilmente non avrei più
potuto fare il fatto di ballare perché
praticavo il pop e probabilmente non è
più potuto ballare come dicevo questo
piede che avranno tanto lo hanno
tagliato non l'hanno tagliata non avevo
coraggio nel guardarmi e alla fine i
miei genitori dopo due giorni l'anno
erano detti credo sia stata
lo so è stato difficilissimo per loro
però ecco in quel momento ho fatto due
laghi e ho detto ok ora che cosa bisogna
fare
infatti da lì è partito tutto diciamo
come dire il calvario se così si può
chiamare ma la cosa brutta è che mi
sentivo di dover affrontare un qualcosa
di enorme sebbene io fossi e mi sentissi
tanto piccola una delle prime cose che
ho dovuto affrontare è stato il fatto di
sentirmi diversa è un diverso
in realtà sono più piani il fatto di
sentirmi diversa rispetto alla mia e di
prima e il fatto di sentirmi diversa
rispetto agli altri e diverse rispetto
al mese prima erano anche le persone che
che interagivano con me a volte ad
accrescere questo sentimento per che
percepivo la differenza percepivo che
tutti mi trattavano in modo diverso nel
senso che se prima si giocava si
scherzava normalmente percepivo quella
sorta di imbarazzo comunque di non
sapere come porsi e a volte non capivo
perché dice ok le mie esigenze i miei
problemi il mio corpo è cambiato però io
mi sento quasi la stessa di prima
diciamo la mia maschera è cambiata non
sono non posso essere più la ragazza
molto sicura di sé la ragazza mi
dispiace dirlo anche un po snob diciamo
chiaro prima avevo ormai distrutto
quella maschera e probabilmente iniziato
a provare a preparare il terreno per
un'altra me che sicuramente avrebbe
dovuto lottare diciamo per riconquistare
una sorta di autostima e il fatto di
sentirmi diverse rispetto agli altri
l'ho capito rianalizzando alcuni dei
sogni più frequenti che facevo
ricordo che solamente cinque giorni dopo
l'incidente avevo sognato di trovarmi in
un negozio di scarpe
nel quale un commesso non mi permetteva
di provarne un paio perché non avevo un
piede era cose mi dicesse non puoi
trovarle perché non sei normale e un
altro sogno invece vedevamo il
protagonista nel mio paesino fare il
bagno con una protesi che in realtà non
sapevo neanche come fosse fatta nel
momento in cui entrava nella come si
ispirava la protesi e tutti intorno ai
miei compagni amici conoscenti non
conoscenti si mettevano a ridere quasi
perfidamente divertiti e anche un po
schifati e io ricordo che nello
svegliarmi dicevo ok questo non dovrà
succedere spero che non succederà ad
oggi mi fa anche un po ridere perché
credo che se dovesse succedere sarei la
prima a prendermi in giro scena
abbastanza comica comunque ecco
ripensandoci capisco che tutte quelle
paure derivano dal fatto che appunto la
paura più grande era quella di mostrarsi
agli altri perché non riuscivo a farlo
nemmeno con me stessa non riuscivo a
guardarmi la gamba non riuscivo a
guardarmi allo specchio quindi come
avrei potuto fare a mostrare le cose
mostrare il mio corpo il mio nuovo porto
agli altri e come l'ho fatto in realtà è
un qualcosa che ho dovuto accettare fino
a trarne qualcosa di positivo
se appunto per me prima era un problema
in realtà dopo già qualche settimana ho
capito che la mia prof
la mia futura protesi e cicatrici
sarebbero state cose che mi avrebbero
distinto dalle altre persone e che
quindi non sarebbero state un problema
in realtà cioè dipenderà molto anche dal
fatto di come io le mostrava agli altri
e infatti è in realtà è una cosa che
forse molti altre persone disabili ecco
sicuramente concorderanno con questo il
fatto che a volte per la maggior parte
delle volte siamo noi a dover mettere a
proprio agio le persone che hai davanti
noi dipende molto da come tu decidi di
portare quella diversità nel senso a
volte anche da una cosa da fastidio se
io anche adesso sono con le stampelle
se decidessi di camminare o comunque è
una giornata no e io cammino senza
sorridere le persone automaticamente
pensano porella quella gli manca una
gamba comunque tutti i problemi anzi al
momento pure il piede che sfigata se io
cammino con il sorriso le persone dicono
grande per la a portare bene ha reagito
ha avuto coraggio e questo è come
appunto deciso di mostrarlo agli altri
no come un qualcosa di semplicemente
diverso quale appunto è anche il fatto
di fare le cose
normalissima di tutti i giorni è un
qualcosa che è cambiato e io in realtà
mi potrei fermare al dire non ho
entrambi i piedi non posso farlo però ho
deciso di vederla come non ho entrambi i
piedi devo trovare un altro modo per
farlo quindi non farei arrampicate non
farei immersioni snowboard quant'altro
se mi fermassi a dire in quel modo in
realtà questa questo lo trovo un po uno
stile di vita diciamo il fatto di
trovare un'alternativa e valorizzare ciò
che sia piuttosto che piangersi addosso
per ciò che non si sa come un voto
comunque torna e questo diceva un
aspetto che comunque possiamo adattare
molte altre situazioni anche il fatto di
piacersi e piacere specie il proprio
corpo è qualcosa che comunque dipende da
tantissimi da tantissimi fattori però il
fatto di non piacersi a volte credo che
derivi da un qualcosa di più grande cioè
il fatto di vedere ogni giorno cioè che
noi ci troviamo tutti i giorni davanti a
mass media comunque pubblicità e riviste
che ci fanno che ci mostrano uno
stereotipo no di bellezza o comunque
spoiler è uno stereotipo di bellezza e
ci porta a dirci come noi dobbiamo
essere cosa dobbiamo fare cosa possiamo
e non possiamo fare è quella e quindi
come dire noi ci sentiamo in dovere di
essere in quel modo perché nessuno in
realtà ci mostra la diversità anche se
ci pensiamo è molto più reale
non esistono è molto difficile
raggiungere la perfezione a meno che non
usiamo photoshop però insomma quello che
vediamo tutti i giorni in realtà è
diversa e per questo ho deciso l'anno
scorso di partecipare a miss italia
perché non avevo mai visto una modella
disabile in una sfilata di alta moda non
ho mai visto un attrice disabile una
conduttrice disabile e quindi ho voluto
partecipare semplicemente per dimostrare
le persone che la mia protesi non doveva
come dire non permettermi di fare
qualcosa che comunque si è noi lo
vediamo è una gamba artificiale è una
gamba finta però a del ed illuminare a
degli strass efficace coscienza
e quindi ai puntualizzò per partecipare
a miss italia non ci sono degli
stereotipi non ci sono modelli da
seguire però credo che questi stereotipi
vivano dentro le persone che guardano
miss italia o dentro ognuno di noi e
quindi ho voluto proprio distruggere
quegli stereotipi e
come dire sono così data è una diversità
si ma è anche normale mi è successo un
incidente niente di che ora vivo e
faccio tutto come tutti e quindi altro
sport
quindi niente il fatto è che credo che
che noi abbiamo paura a mostrarci per
quelli che siamo veramente
abbiamo paura a distinguersi dalla massa
perché fondamentalmente anche la storia
ci ha sempre insegnato che ci vuole
coraggio a distinguersi e noi in realtà
quello che vorrei raggiungere in un
futuro quel passo in avanti che ancora
dobbiamo fare è proprio il fatto di
vedere una protesi ad esempio e
vederla come un qualcosa di normale cioè
io vorrei che in un futuro la mia
protesi passasse in secondo piano e
diventasse una sorta di di dettaglio
quasi insignificante magari in un futuro
vedremo delle persone con i capelli rosa
o con i pantaloni fluorescenti o in
carrozzina sarà una cosa del tutto
normale non penseremo a non ci faremo
dei pregiudizi in base a quello che
vediamo ma andremo oltre e penseremo
dietro a quei capelli rosa dietro a
quelle ruote o dietro a quelle stampelle
c'è una persona in realtà che ha già
visto con un passato
e questa l'immagine che mi piace
particolarmente perché ero in thailandia
in un villaggio in realtà piccolo di
persone che vivono di commercio mercanti
diciamo così si possono chiamare e nel
momento in cui i bambini mi hanno visto
la protesi sono rimasti come dire
incuriositi da ad una gamba noi sembrava
qualcosa di bionico e ho fatto caso che
a volte è diverso rispetto le persone
più grandi nostri genitori non ci dicono
nulla o comunque non ci preparano al
vedere una diversità in realtà diversa
cioè di questi questi bambini erano
semplicemente curiosi e mi è capitato
anche di andare al mare anni fa e
con la mia mamma ovviamente fuori allo
scoperto e vedere mamme che giravano lo
sguardo ai bambini cioè quel bambino
crescerà sempre con l'idea che è
sbagliato vuol dire di diverso vuol dire
sbagliato e questo è quello che è
veramente mi mi è piaciuto di questa
esperienza è quello che mi piace in
generale vedere la curiosità innocente
cioè andare oltre e pensare solo che
cos'è
e per concludere la mia esperienza mi ha
mi hai imparato premiazione dove la cosa
mi ha insegnato veramente tanto e mi ha
insegnato soprattutto a non avere paura
mia a non aver paura di mostrare chi
sono a non aver paura di dire come la
penso a non aver paura di mostrare un
qualcosa che dagli altri visto come
difetto perché fondamentalmente mi piace
quasi vantarmi della mia protesi delle
cicatrici perché raccontano tanto di me
raccontano tutte le mie sconfitte ma
soprattutto tutte tutte le mie vittorie
e non non ho la presunzione insomma di
voler insegnare niente a nessuno anzi
sicuramente sono l'ultima persona sono
una ragazzina e quindi non posso
insegnarvi nulla però se posso darvi un
consiglio da quel comparato io amate
tutto ciò che vi rende diversi tutto ciò
che vi distingue dagli altri perché in
realtà è tutto quello che sta in quell
insieme a determinare chi siete
veramente e se ci pensate quando ci
innamoriamo di una persona lavoriamo di
chi nella nostra mente si è distinta da
tutte le altre
quindi amate ciò che avete di diverso
perché credo sia la vera bellezza
[Applauso]